so i'm going to talk about my favorite
number at the moment which is the number
two thousand
and twenty-five it's just it's 45
um squared so it's a square number and
don't get me wrong big fan love square
numbers but there are loads of square
numbers and none of them become my
favorite number this one because my
favorite number for a very personal
reason and the reason i absolutely love
it is that in the year
2025 i will turn 45.
and so for a brief moment
i will turn
the exact square root of the then
current yeah what a birthday party
that's going to be it's going to go off
and it's very rare so very few people
get this it happens to me because i was
born in the year 1980 and so if you're
born in 1980
and you age 45 years that's going to
occur in the year 2025 which is 45
squared and so i get to be the age n
in year n squared and that is absolutely
brilliant and if you look around the
room or as you go about your life look
at all the masses of people out there
none of them
will get to experience this
undiluted mathematical birthday joy
unless like me they were born in 1980
it's just me and my fellow 98ers who get
to enjoy this because if you were born
any other year people who are currently
alive well okay people born in 1979
are all like oh but we will still be 45
at the beginning of the year and then
we'll turn 46 no what are you
celebrating the end of it working right
you want the birthday in the year so all
the people this previously happened to
has happened before they're all dead so
back in 1892
people who then aged 44 years
in the year uh what's that going to be i
mean
that's right 19
uh 36
that
1936 equals 44 yeah that's right square
and so 1936 quite the year but no one is
still around from the year 1892
and it's not going to happen again until
the year 2070.
so 2070 those people when they turn 46
which will occur in the year 2116
which is 46
squared you thought about what you're
gonna do for your birthday oh my
goodness i don't know i mean i've still
got a few i got a decade of planning to
go and it's gonna it'll be square themed
all the food will be square shaped and
not cubes not cuboids people are
thinking square cake no it is the
infinitely thin slices of square cake
although there are a few other people
who not alive at the moment this is the
only one who will get to be in the
future
at the very least a root a nice whole
route of the then current year and it's
no i mean no one alive now you don't get
no one else will be the cube root any
other power
but there are a few coming up in the
near future so if you want a time when
you're going to reproduce so that your
future generations have the best chance
if you carry on with the squaring one
you get another year in 21
which is the next one that's when 47
gives you
2209 which is 47 square but frankly that
is a i mean that's a bit of a weight
before then in the year 2046
which is not too bad we're talking
your children's children so your
grandkids you'll be around to see this
one
when they turn
that will be the year 2048
which is 2 to the power of 11. and so
they will very briefly be the 11th root
and as a bigger point though
powers of two amazing numbers we haven't
had a power two since the year 10 24.
it's been over a millennia since the
last over a millennium
well it's been over one of them since
the last time i had a power to the next
one's not for another 2000 years i mean
40 96 is the next time we get one of
these so i mean just as a year what a
time to be alive
oh my goodness forget hayley's comment
forget you know
uh transit of venus
this you've got to wait thousands of
years for when it happens so come on
2048 is going to go off i messed around
with all the other possible powers
various years where that happens and
they're all so infrequent there are so
few but then
i stumbled across the year
and this this i don't know if this is as
amazing as i think it is the year 2184
and let's be honest it's a way off i
mean we've got a lot to go between here
and there and we're talking how many
generations i mean that's
distant relatives will be around we will
be a long forgotten thing maybe youtube
will still be around us some kind of
archival reference maybe you're watching
this in a history class right now in the
year 2184 how do you feel about people
watching youtube i know hello from the
past uh this this this is how we used to
live
here are i mean these these are we used
to use dead trees
to store information and although maybe
all of anything digital will be
destroyed and people have no idea about
youtube but they'll still have these
books we don't know but anyway in the
year 2184 and i'm talking directly to
those of you in 2184 now what a year by
anyone being born in your year or if you
were born in 2184 you will at two
different occasions in your lifetime be
the exact root of the then current and
this just blew my mind when i noticed
this so if you were born in 2184
and you wait a little while and you age
uh which we'll do three first if you age
three years
so you're still very young you're
probably unaware of what's going on
around you that will then be the year
and
2187 equals
3 to the power of seven
and so you will be when you're three
you will be the s the seventh root of
the then current year but then
born in exactly the same year later on
in your life when you turn 13 so at
least you're now forming permanent
memories that would be the year 2197
and that equals
cubed
and so you will then be the cube root of
the then current year
at the very least uh it's been great
talking to people from the distant 22nd
century i am i hope you're having a
great time in the future
here's the thing i'm talking about over
here and oh here we have a clock we used
to use this to tell the time when we
physically rotated objects to point at a
kind of rooms that we would arrange in a
circle and these are cables we used to
send information down these using
electrons so we would send very specific
electrons along and oh this is a switch
we had to physically hit things to
change our environment and so we had to
push thing oh this
this was an early we use this as
sustenance so this is a basic food that
you can both use and
attach things to vertical surfaces